alright guys we are loaded up tonight
you are not going to want to miss one
moment of this show but first we're only
now learning why former FBI director Jim
Comey contorted himself to not indict
Hillary Clinton regarding her use of a
private email server during her time as
Secretary of State tonight we can tell
you that it appears that the FBI's lead
investigator and deputy chief of
counter-intel has been revealed to be
just another Clinton crony and Trump
hater Peter struck was found to have
exchanged anti-trump texts during the
2016 presidential debates with another
colleague at the Justice Department this
according to the New York Times and get
this he attended Hillary's pre 4th of
July interview that was never
transcribed and he reportedly urged call
me to strike the phrase grossly
negligent to describe Hillary Clinton's
handling of classified information he
softened it to extremely careless
although we did not find clear evidence
that Secretary Clinton or her colleagues
intended to violate laws governing the
handling of classified information there
is evidence that they were extremely
careless in their handling of very
sensitive highly classified information
unbelievable and this gets better
this same partisan official was one of
the lead investigators assigned to the
bureau's Trump Russia inquiry he was
very busy and not only that he was also
part of the interview team that
questioned Trump national security
adviser Mike Flynn on January 24th huh
what a coincidence this guy is just
everywhere but wait there's more mr.
struck was a pal of commis he wasn't
taken off the case by special counsel
robert muller until this past summer in
july so why the heck didn't Muller
inform the public given the stakes
involved and the need for public trust
in this investigation why did he tell
anyone
Scylla's was writing anti-trump tax
during the debates so much for
transparency and of course let's not
forget we have a gaggle of anti Trump
Pro Hillary prosecutors who are still
working for Muller right now my friends
this is unacceptable it's disgusting and
it's unfair tonight I urge the do J's
Inspector General who seems like a
terrific guy Michael Horowitz to release
a full transcript of mr. structs text
and maybe even those of other key
Clinton and Russia investigators now
remember this is the same man who helped
lead the investigation into the
so-called Trump Russia collusion this
mr. struck character I have a question
how can anyone at this point just
learning this fact and the other facts
that we've cited on this show
trust the Muller office at this point no
transparency they're not telling us the
truth about this and we're only learning
it when the Inspector General somehow
releases this information to the public
since the Mike Flynn plea deal just last
week the media experts are predicting oh
it's curtains it's over for the Trump
presidency
r.i.p Donald Trump's political life but
I'll tell you what's obvious here it is
although Flynn did lie the collusion
case died so now they're on to the
so-called obstruction of justice case
against President Trump the experts
think it's all cut and dried display the
public record there's one piece of
evidence for obstruction of justice
after another and this seems to be
Exhibit one that seems to be in the
territory of obstruction of justice I
think what we're beginning to see is the
putting together of case of obstruction
of justice move over f lee Bailey yeah
so are worried should Trump be at this
point well time will tell
we don't really know at this point but
consider that the media and legal and
political experts
who are predicting Trump's impeachment
they also predicted this about the
president's travel ban there's a
discriminatory intent here and the
discriminatory intent of the Trump
administration is clear it was a premise
on religious discrimination it's very
clear that the president is acting
unconstitutional you said we don't want
to ban any big on the basis of religion
and that's against our Constitution but
that's exactly what they're doing thank
you for calling it what it is I'm gonna
call it what it is it's a Muslim ban
well today a refreshingly sane order by
the Supreme Court on president Trump's
so-called travel ban of six mostly
Muslim countries well the court declined
to halt the ban despite rulings in two
different lower courts this was a
preliminary but nevertheless a major
victory for President Trump who always
had the constitutional right to
determine the classes of people who can
and cannot enter the country for
security reasons now once again the
experts are wrong and while the media
has a case of the vapor is a total
meltdown over Flynn's cooperation with
Muller the president is racking up win
after win tax cuts are coming retail is
soaring this Christmas season the market
is way up and now a key win at the
Supreme Court and it's only Monday my
friends and that's the angle